it has been
2809 days since Donald Trump first
descended that golden escalator and
announced his bid for president and the
libs are still trying to lock him up
for something
anything
first they spied on his campaign
when that turned up nothing they
launched a special counsel investigation
to NAB him for allegedly colluding with
the Russians
when that didn't work they impeached him
for allegedly colluding with the
ukrainians
when that didn't work they impeached him
again for allegedly trying to overthrow
the government
when that didn't work
they impaneled a grand jury in Georgia
to investigate him for allegedly
pressuring the Georgia Secretary of
State Brad raffensberger
to challenge the results of the election
that is where we are now
and here is the foreman of that grand
jury Emily Coors explaining on National
Television what she hopes will come of
the investigation
after everything that you've seen what
would your reaction be if the D.A
decides against bringing any charges
after what you've seen
I will be sad if nothing happens
like that's that's about my only request
there is is for something to happen I
don't necessarily know what it is I'm
not the legal expert I'm not the judge
I'm not the lawyers but
I I will be frustrated if nothing
happens this was too much
twitch information too much of my time
too much of everyone's time too much of
their time
too much argument in in court about
getting people to appear before us there
was just too much for this to just be
oh okay we're good bye
and if it was just a perjury charge or
perjury charges would that be acceptable
to you that's fine
I would be happy as long as something
happens
ha ha something anything it's just taken
up so much time and effort not just for
her for all the libs who have spent now
seven years trying to get this guy each
time being foiled like Wiley Coyote
and after this grand jury Foreman's
extremely imprudent media tour which
could result in the whole shebang being
tossed out of court
it looks as though Roadrunner Donald has
managed to avoid yet another Acme Anvil
I'm Michael Knowles this the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Carrie art 7
who says this video had so many bleeps
you'd think Michael was doing a rap song
No the difference is that my show is
actually subversive to the regime that
we're living under whereas rap music
which pretends to be subversive is not
at all subversive it actually just
promotes and upholds that that regime
most of the time there were some bleeps
in yesterday's show this is because
you know big Tech platforms have all
sorts of rules and they change the
censorship rules constantly
and I don't like to be censored it's
kind of funny because I am the most Pro
censorship in principle conservative
possibly out there I wrote a whole book
about it called speechless controlling
words controlling Minds available now to
order hello thank you very much however
I support just and prudent censorship
weird porn stuff obscenity threats fraud
all that stuff should be censored but I
am very opposed to unjust censorship and
so when some big Tech platform has some
absurd and unjust rule about censorship
I'm not going to keep my mouth shut even
if they threaten to strike my account
again to take down the video at the very
least I'm going to make clear what the
censorship is and then direct you to
dailywire.com Knowles if you want to see
the the raw uncut
unbleeped Edition I'm like a cool rapper
in the 90s you know you gotta head over
there for the 17 plus
rated R kind of version of this show
okay now you can do all of that from the
comfort of your home you can also have
your propane tank changed from the
comfort of your home that's why you
gotta check out cinch right now go to
cinch.com use promo code nulls you need
to get a million things done today if
there are ways to help you accomplish
your ginormous task list why wouldn't
you jump on that cinch is a propane
grill tank Home Delivery Service they
deliver propane tanks right to your door
cinch delivers on your schedule no
long-term commitment or subscription is
required plus delivery is completely
contactless you don't have to be home to
receive the delivery you can track the
order on the Cinch app from anywhere
whether you're grilling camping or
enjoying a cozy fire on a cold winter
night cinches propane delivery service
ensures that you have the fuel that you
need to make the most of every moment go
to online to cinch.com or download their
app to order new customers can get their
first tank exchange for just 10 bucks
with promo code Knowles kwles go to
cinch.com or download the Cinch app and
use Pro promo code nulls to get your
first tank exchange for just ten dollars
cynch.com promo code nulls the weather
is warming up we're getting ready for a
nice Grill season it's a limited time
offer you must live with an essential
service area to redeem it go to
cinch.com
offer for details
what is the Georgia grand jury even
about I had to remind myself of this
yesterday I said wait hold on they got
him now they are so close to getting
Trump again for something and then ah
foiled again at the last moment by this
this eccentric grand jury Foreman but
wait what are they getting him for now
and the grant the grand jury in Georgia
is about a phone call on January 2nd
2021 so just after the 2020 election
it's an hour-long conference call
that then president Donald Trump had
with Georgia Secretary of State Brad
raffensberger
and according to the reporting
it was Trump pressuring the Secretary of
State to cheat to change the results of
the election to hand it to Trump when
Biden really won it that's not what
happened that's not even if you look at
the details of what the Liberals say
about this phone call that's not what
they say happened
what the Liberals say about this phone
call
we have the transcript of it is they say
that Donald Trump said this
what I want is this I just want to find
uh 11 780 votes which is one more than
we have
the margin of defeat at that point was
eleven thousand seven hundred seventy
nine votes just one more than we have
now if the if the sentence ended there
you might say okay well maybe he's
pressuring the Georgia Secretary of
State to just make up a number and add
it to Trump's tally to steal the
election but that's not where the
sentence ends he says I just want to
find 11 780 votes which is one more than
we have because we won the state
he's saying we won the state
and the tally doesn't reflect that now
you might disagree you might say Trump
is delusional you might say there were
no Shenanigans in Georgia you might say
that there were no pipes bursting in the
middle of the night and that the pole
washers were watching everything and it
didn't take a very long time to count
those ballots and there weren't all
sorts of Shenanigans in Georgia that it
would appear that there were I certainly
think there were a lot of Shenanigans in
Georgia but you might say I totally
disagree with Trump that's not the point
the point is what was Trump saying on
the phone call Trump was saying we won
the state and I want the tally to
reflect that that's a very different
thing than saying we lost the state but
I want you to cheat and pretend that we
won it so the whole
non-traversing I think is laughable to
begin with and now we are seeing just
how laughable it is when this grand jury
Foreman is exposing it as a witch hunt
this woman Emily Coors
who who is the top juror now on this
grand jury
you she divulged
some information that she probably
shouldn't have not just about Trump but
about all sorts of indictments that may
or may not come down
is it would you say when it comes to
there are there are indictments
recommended of course is it more than 12
people is it more than 20 people
I think if you look at the page numbers
of the report there's about
six pages in the middle that got cut out
allow for spacing
it's not a short list
not a short list did you personally want
to hear from the formula I wanted to
hear from the former president but
honestly I kind of wanted to subpoena
the former president because I got to
swear everybody in and so I thought it'd
be really cool to get 60 seconds with
President Trump of me looking at him and
being like do you solemnly swear I'm
beginning to swear him in I just I kind
of just thought that would be an awesome
moment huh that's not as shirtless she's
talking about all sorts of things that
she should not be talking about
she's talking about witnesses that they
saw she's she's describing the witnesses
she said I found some of them credible
some of them I found funny saying all
sorts of things she shouldn't say and
then what's at the end I just really
wanna
be able to swear in Trump wouldn't that
be awesome
wouldn't that be so awesome
this might
destroy the entire prosecution case
against all of these people they might
have to throw the whole thing out and
then here's the kicker on top of it the
kicker on top I got to give credit to
jack besobic for this
Jack found a Pinterest account that
would appear to belong to this woman and
the Pinterest account includes different
Pinterest boards
about
witchcraft
so there's one about Wicca witchcraft
paganism all sorts of occult weird
spiritualist practices pages and pages
of this which means
because all eight all Natures but art
unknown to thee all chance Direction
which thou canst not see what that means
is
this is a literal Witch Hunt and it's
not a Witch Hunt in the sense that
people are hunting witches it's a Witch
Hunt in the sense that witches are
hunting Donald Trump it's an actual you
can't even
if you if a Hollywood scriptwriter turns
this into a producer the producer would
reject it for being too outrageous and
too on the nose
they would say oh no this grand jury
Foreman character this is too absurd
this would never really have they would
never say these things on National
Television she couldn't be an actual
witch no come on but that is
that is what's happening
it would appear to be a literal Witch
Hunt which it always has been
Trump for his part is looking great
Trump yesterday went to East Palestine
Ohio the Buddha judge hasn't been there
Joe Biden hasn't been there Joe Biden's
been too busy paddling around with his
buddy Vladimir zielinski and Kiev so he
hasn't had time to go visit his own
citizens in Ohio after a trained
derailment poisoned the air and the
water in that town that's that's flyover
country Biden's not going to make it
there so Trump shows up and Trump
Trump makes a few different stops in the
town one of which my favorite of which
is in a McDonald's
hello everybody that's a nice beautiful
looking beautiful people so I know this
menu better than you do okay I probably
know it better than anybody in here why
are you visiting today well we brought a
lot of people with us and more
importantly we brought the federal
government with us because uh when they
heard I was coming they all came they
weren't going to come they would have
leave you abandoned and now they're not
uh the owner over here he saw that I
helped out all the responders and
everything in the first week I was out
here making Egg McMuffins myself
Saturday morning
he did a good job so give us a nice
array of stuff take care of the people
and I'll see you later okay
can I get a picture with you
this is
vintage perfect Trump this is the best
version of trump
when Trump shows up to a McDonald's and
he says listen great to be with you all
I love being here I know this menu
better than you workers do
that's a great moment because it's
believable it's sincere the guy actually
loves McDonald's something that people
really like about Trump a lot of the
Republican establishment never
understood this they say how is it that
these working-class people like this
billionaire who was born into wealth and
who's been a Playboy Billionaire's whole
life
because Donald Trump's tastes
are the tastes of regular people
Donald Trump's comportment
behavior is the behavior of Regular
People Donald Trump's priorities or the
priorities of regular people that's why
yes he was born into a lot of wealth the
man actually loves McDonald's and
probably knows the McDonald's menu
better than most of the workers of that
franchise
yes Donald Trump was born into wealth
and into High Society but
for one he wasn't exactly accepted by
the elite Society in New York
but even beyond that his priorities his
affections his political vision is much
closer to the political vision of
blue-collar workers in the Rust Belt
than it is to some guy working at a
think tank in Washington DC you see that
on trade you see that on immigration you
see that on national identity you see
that on everything okay so if if Joe
Biden showed up here said I'll have a
give me a triple double large Mac please
you wouldn't believe you just think Joe
Biden this guy doesn't go to McDonald's
but Trump shows up he goes hey everybody
we're gonna have a great meal at
McDonald's that it it it brings you
something
in the political scene That You Don't
See very much which is it's not just
some policy it's not just some photo op
it's it's through loss it's spiritedness
it's a it's a a sense that this guy
this guy's very essence share is a kind
of similarity to his constituents and
that is a very very powerful in politics
now if you know if you eat too much junk
food it's probably going to kill you and
when you die some yeah you're going to
want a will right now go to epicwill.com
Knowles to save 10 percent
100 of people will die someday that's a
fact according to a recent poll 62
percent of Americans who think about
their own death a lot of the time don't
have a will that's kind of weird kind of
like being afraid that your house will
burn down but not having homeowners
insurance
being afraid of drowning but refusing to
wear a life jacket you need to have a
will I put it off for years too don't
put it off any longer especially with
epic will like it's so fast to get done
and then you just get that peace of mind
and you know what's going to happen to
your stuff and your money and most
importantly your kids creating a will is
one of the most important things that
you can do to ensure that your
belongings and your loved ones are taken
care of after you die our partners over
at Epic will will help you get set up
with will today for just 119 bucks in as
little as five minutes epic will can
help you create your last will and
testament your living will your
Healthcare power of attorney go to
epicwill.com
get my discount code and save an extra
10 on your complete whale package
epicwill.com slash Knowles ten percent
on Epic Wheels complete wheel package
that is epicwill.com
Knowles Donald Trump did not show up to
East Palestine empty-handed
Donald Trump also gave a big rally and
he brought a lot of supplies and he
brought a lot of water as he explained
in great detail
especially thanks some of the incredible
people that helped us because we're
bringing thousands of bottle of water
Trump water actually most of it uh some
of it we had to go to a much lesser
Quality Water
you want to get those Trump bottles I
think more than anybody else but we're
bringing a lot of water
love it this again
the Liberals just don't know how to
interpret this there were liberals
freaking out on social media they said
Donald Trump he's there Shilling his
water how Shameless is he he's trying no
he's not
he's not selling his water he's not
selling it to the citizens of East
Palestine I don't think he sells it
period I don't think you can go to a
grocery store and buy Trump water
why is he talking about Trump water I'm
sure that's just the water he picked up
at his hotels and golf clubs and
Mar-A-Lago so he happens to have that
water and he loaded it on but it wasn't
enough compared to what they wanted to
bring so they brought some other water
too and then Trump goes in
and he makes a joke about it
and it's funny and everybody gets the
joke except for the humorless elite
liberals who are still plotting out like
Wiley Coyote had to drop the next piano
on his head until the Road Runner runs
away too fast
look we got we brought a lot of water
brought a lot of trump water actually
that's the water you want to get that's
the good one we brought some much lesser
Quality Water it's still the water that
he brought very generously donated it to
East Palestine but he's just
I I was really really gratified to see
this in East Palestine one because he
actually is calling attention to it when
they say what else did you bring he said
I brought the federal government is what
I brought because no one was paying
attention to this and then I'm showing
up and now Biden has to show up which is
good and and that's something that Trump
has brought to politics ever since he
came down that golden escalator so I'm
glad to see that the other thing I'm
glad to see is it feels like he's kind
of getting his mojo back
he at his announcement at Mar-A-Lago it
was kind of weak sauce some of the
appearances he's been making recently
have been just kind of
Bland they haven't had that Trump magic
but this was a really great this was a
really great political event it was good
for the citizens it was good for Trump's
campaign it it presented him as himself
as this American original
he's the guy who's going to show up and
donate a lot of supplies because he's
got a lot of money he's got more money
than most of the candidates in the race
at least maybe all of them
he's gonna he's gonna tell some jokes
he's gonna lift some people's spirits
and he's going to seem
paradoxically like one of them
there is not one candidate in the GOP
field who likes McDonald's more than
Donald Trump and that is a powerful
political tool it seems trivial but
that's a powerful political tool
speaking of speaking of the
water around East Palestine
a grocery chain has pulled water that
happens to be bottled near East
Palestine and you might say why are they
doing that Michael we've been told by
all the officials that the water is
totally fine remember the EPA
administrator comes in and says that
water around East Palestine you know
where they just dumped a gazillion
gallons of chemicals that are extremely
toxic and some of which were used as
poison gases in World War one yeah no
it's fine drink the water you're all
good
now what happens JD Vance the Republican
senator shows up
he's looking at some water he throws a
rock in a creek and then everything
looks like an oily rainbow
there are clearly so many chemicals in
the water
so this grocery store chain Giant Eagle
is pulling from its shelves bottled
water sourced from a facility near East
Palestine Ohio they say out of an
abundance of caution
Giant Eagle has made the decision to
remove all gallon size or greater Giant
Eagle brand Spring Water Products
sourced from salineville facility
that's right near East Palestine until
further notice until we continue to
evaluate ongoing testing and potential
impacts to the spring source
the water is obviously poisoned this is
not out of an abundance of caution this
is out of the very bare minimum of
caution of course people don't want to
buy it
the grocery store chain doesn't want to
be on the hook if people get poisoned
from this stuff so they're pulling it
absolutely right yes this contradicts
what we've been told by the EPA
administrator but look at people's
behavior
people's behavior is going to tell you
very often a lot more than their words
are
all the liberal politicians say the
water's totally safe the air is totally
safe but they're not going to show up
are they haven't made it there yet to
East Palestine they haven't breathed
that air in the two weeks after the the
crash three weeks now
they haven't had that water to drink the
Ohio Senator the Democrat Ohio Senator
was interviewed on TV
and he was asked Sherrod Brown will you
and the other officials in this town
drink the water he evaded the question
no they're not going to drink the water
they think it's poison they might tell
you they don't think that but look at
their behavior
they might tell you it's not poison
we'll look at the behavior of the
grocery store what does that tell you it
means you can't take what these people
say at face value you've got to conduct
your own research which is something
that Elite Liberals are really upset
about they are really upset
that in the last few years specifically
you have been thinking for yourself
conducting your own research which is
very easy to do now you can just pull up
Google and you can find credible sources
and you can look with your own true eyes
and see that reality is contradicting
what the Liberals tell you and they
don't like that Sam Harris
who is atypical Elite liberal
he is an archetype for almost he he is
an atheist
a
at least self-styled intellectual
a media figure
a
a person who Embraces the mantle of
science
he says
he just posted this to his Instagram
account
during the pandemic we witnessed the
birth of a new religion of contrarianism
and conspiracy thinking the first
sacrament of which is to do your own
research
the problem is that very few people are
qualified to do this research and the
result is a society driven by strongly
held unfounded opinions on everything
from vaccine safety to the war in
Ukraine
do your own research you people you're
not qualified to do your own research
you have to leave that to Dr fauci he
gets everything right
do your own research you have to leave
that to the EPA administrator they get
everything right don't they
no
well what have they gotten wrong
recently
okay maybe they were wrong about the
severity of covid
and the origin of covid
and the efficacy of the masks and the
vaccines we'll get to that in just one
second
and maybe they not only were wrong maybe
they actually lied to you in some cases
and maybe they don't even know the
difference between men and women and
maybe they're wrong about
a lot of things but you should not do
your own research this is
this is a paradox of liberalism
and when I say liberalism I don't just
mean modern leftist progressively I mean
kind of the whole liberal tradition
going back to
Classical liberalism the the whole
political ideology that's dominated the
last three four hundred years the
Paradox is this liberalism tells you
to reject tradition reject Prejudice
reject received opinion
think for yourself
we're not going to teach you what to
think only how to think you need to be
radically skeptical you need to examine
everything yourself don't take anything
by Authority or face value reject
tradition think for yourself and also
what the Liberals will tell you is don't
think for yourself you're not qualified
to do it the Paradox here is that when
you reject tradition
and when you think that you can know
everything that there is to know only
through your unfettered reason
you will end up losing both tradition
and reason you will you will not have
tradition to God Joe you'll lose that
and you won't be able to think for
yourself
the conservatives offer an alternative
to that the conservatives say don't
reject tradition don't reject Prejudice
don't reject receive opinion actually
the the people who came before you for
the thousands of years of of your
tradition
maybe their accumulated wisdom might be
a little more interesting than the
random thought you had last night at two
in the morning maybe there's something
you can learn from all of the
generations going back Millennia from
all of the wisdom accumulated over the
ages
and then
think for yourself
apply all of that wisdom all of that
knowledge and and use your own faculties
of reason there
the Paradox of liberalism is that the
Liberals who say that they are the most
independent thinkers in the world
are the least likely people to think for
themselves
and this is not just some cheap
political shot that Aya conservative and
making about them Sam Harris a leading
public liberal is telling you that's
what liberalism says
Sam Harris is admitting
that that for most people they cannot
think for themselves
that's his view as a liberal that's not
my view as a conservative and if you
look at the liberals who insisted follow
fauci follow the EPA follow the who
follow follow follow for the last three
years and you look at the tinfoil hat
conservative conspiracy theorist
contrarians who's been more right the
conservatives the contrarians the
conspiracy theorists crazy tinfoil hat
people have been right statistically 100
of the time and those liberal Geniuses
following Sam Harris and the rest of
these
people
have been wrong statistically one
hundred percent of the time in recent
years
speaking of conspiracy theories
let's just examine a couple of those
remember
and this is this speaks to exactly what
Sam Harris was talking about
they these contrarian conspiracists they
question the science on vaccines
these contrarian conspiracists they
question the science on masks okay new
study out from George Mason
examining the efficacy of vaccine
mandates Citywide
I'm just quoting from the study you can
bleep me if you want to social media
platforms but this is just what the
study says this is the science I'm
following it these mandates
the vaccine mandates imposed severe
restrictions on the lives of many
citizens and business owners
yet we find no evidence that the
mandates were effective in their
intended goals of reducing covid-19
cases and deaths
researchers evaluated New York La Boston
Chicago New Orleans Philadelphia San
Francisco Seattle and Washington D.C
we're talking about a lot of city-wide
vaccine mandates rather
they say we find no evidence
that the announcement or implementation
of indoor vaccine mandates in the cities
listed had any significant effect on
vaccine uptake covid-19 cases or
covid-19 deaths and this is largely
consistent for all U.S cities that
implemented the mandate
that's just the vaccine mandates the
vaccine mandates that when they came
down
some of us I'm not listen I'm not
I'm not boasting I'm not you know how
much I hate to say I told you so but
some of us said this is bogus this is
ridiculous don't do this fauci's
terrible he's wrong about everything
don't listen to him
and then all the really fancy people all
the Sam Harris people said no you've got
to follow the fauci okay
we were totally right we were 100
completely right about the efficacy of
these vaccine mandate policies
furthermore what about the masks I
always made fun of the masks
they're all the Liberals loved the masks
many conservatives self-styled
conservatives loved the masks all the
Liberals love the vaccines even many
self-styled conservatives love the
vaccines
I thought the vaccines were bogus from
day one and I thought the masks were
especially bogus from day one
and so okay we've now done away with the
vaccine mandate so thank you George
Mason University how about the mask
mandates well I've got the New York
Times no less a liberal Source than the
New York Times
headline
The Mask mandates did nothing
will any lessons be learned
the most rigorous and comprehensive
analysis of scientific studies conducted
on the efficacy of masks for reducing
the spread of respiratory illnesses
including covid-19 was published late
last month its conclusions said Tom
Jefferson the Oxford epidemiologist who
is its lead author were unambiguous
quote
there is just no evidence that they
masks make any difference
full stop
but wait hold on what about n95 masks as
opposed to lower quality surgical or
cloth masks
makes no difference
none of it
end quote
completely bogus as We Know
you had to put your little kids in The
Masks if you sent them to school or
daycare If you flew on airplanes you had
to wear the masks until very very
recently
until a trump appointed judge shot the
whole thing down single-handedly
otherwise the mask mandates would
probably still be in place
you may have lost your job
because of the vaccine mandate
you may have I'm sure you know somebody
who lost a job maybe you had to leave
the the service the the military service
Public Health Service Maybe
your life was really really wrecked by
the liberals who were they're so smart
they have so much education
and they have such white lab coats
and your crazy conspiracy theorist
tinfoil hat wearing
three tooth having
uneducated
rube irredeemable deplorable idiot uncle
was much more correct about all of it
all of it
what do we do in these cases we have to
spike the football I remember I said I
hate to say I Told You So in this case
we really have to love to say we told
you so we have to spike the football so
hard on all of these studies we have to
spike the football in front of the
science simps
we have to spike the football so hard in
front of Sam Harris who seems like an
amiable enough guy but who's just wrong
about everything I'm not sure there was
a person walking around today more wrong
about everything than Sam Harris
even though Sam Harris he's clubbable
he's he sounds air you diet he's so
reasonable sounding but he's not he's
one of the least reasonable people in
the country all of these all these
really nice area diet institutional
liberal people
they're the ones who led this country
off a cliff for three years and you
should never let them forget it
if you've got to pick a side politics is
about groups of people it's about people
it's the art of inclusion let's not
forget
which side are you going to be on the
really fancy Elite people or the people
inside McDonald's in East Palestine Ohio
whose government has essentially tried
to ignore them not forgotten about them
is desperately trying to ignore them
which side are you on I'm on the side of
those people in that McDonald's in our
East Palestine Ohio not just because
it's good for politics not just because
it's a helpful strategy for Republicans
to win but because those people have it
more correct they're right about more
things than the liberal Elites who run
our country
that's the way it goes the medical
science
the the all that all the the expert
people
they're wrong about a lot you want to
talk about dubious Medical Science in
the UK the largest pediatric gender
Clinic is under Fire right now because
it ignored a
very closely associated with
transgenderism
new book out it's called time to think
the inside story of the collapse of the
tavistocks set gender service for
children
by BBC News night journalist Hannah
Barnes alleges that Tavistock which
we've reported on in this show before it
was one of the most notorious
transiting the kids centers in the UK
that the Tavistock Clinic which is an
NHS facility public facility in the UK
officially called the gender identity
development service ignored evidence
that 97.5 percent of children seeking
chemical and surgical sex reassignment
Services who sought tranzing the kids
had
thank you or other problems that may
have explained their unhappiness I first
was awakened to this fact when I was
giving a speech I forget which school I
was giving a speech and a girl comes up
to me
and she says hey Michael it was a speech
on transgenderism and I'd been
criticized by all the Liberals for
saying that transgenderism is delusional
and we shouldn't just go about chopping
off the healthy organs of children who
have other problems and she said Michael
thank you so much for saying that I was
gender dysphoric for years and I
really wanted to identify as a boy and I
talked to counselors about this and she
said fortunately I have a strong good
family
and it's a good Catholic Family and we
have good priests and the priest in my
family told me you are not really a boy
you've definitely got some problems but
whatever your problems are you are not
really a boy so there's got to be some
other explanation and they push back on
the doctors who are peddling this gender
Madness and they say no there's got to
be some other explanation and what
happens the girl tells me
she had undiagnosed autism
and apparently according to perfectly
scientific and credible and journalistic
reports
a lot of people a lot of young people
who think that they are the opposite sex
or have
that are not symptoms of gender
dysphoria
they are probably more fundamental
underlying conditions and when you treat
those conditions the gender dysphoria is
greatly alleviated that's what this girl
told me
and for a doctor to have a troubled kid
come in
and the kid comes in and says hey Doc
I've got all these social problems and
and all these
and so I think the solution is you
should you should pump me full of
chemicals stop my puberty later on down
the road chop off my genitals the doctor
says yeah that seems like the simplest
solution okay
okay go get the knives ready let's go
that is such insane medical malpractice
we talked yesterday on the show about
how a detransitioner in Canada is suing
her doctor's right Sue all these people
sue them into the ground remove their
licenses keep them as far away from the
doctor's office and certainly from the
surgical room as possible
speaking of wielding the politics to
this effect this is the sort of thing
you're seeing right now down in Florida
so we talked about how Trump is doing a
great job setting himself up for 2024.
here's how DeSantis is doing a great job
setting himself up for for 2024.
there is legislation being proposed in
Florida by a state senator there
that would hold businesses responsible
for the cost of de-transition care so
you can't you can never really
de-transition there are still going to
be plenty of physical effects if you
pump yourself full of hormones certainly
if you chop off your organs but there
are certain procedures you have to try
to reverse some of the damage uh the the
legislation would force companies
who provide sex change
treatment
to also pay to reverse the sex change
surgeries this is Senate Bill 952 it's
called the reverse woke act filed by
Republican senator Blaise ingolia I love
this bill would make those employers
accountable for the full cost of trend
detransition care even if an individual
is no longer working at that company if
the if the individual were working at
that company and had access to insurance
or some stipend to get the transgender
surgery
that worker could go back later and say
Hey you owe me money to go back
ingolia says woke businesses need to be
held accountable when offering to pay
for gender affirming surgeries in other
states such as California because they
are nothing more than political
decisions masquerading as health care
and human resource decisions
the squishes are going to say this is an
undue burden on businesses I say this is
actually a great help to businesses
which we'll get to in one second first
though folks you know it is no secret
that the libs hate our country they want
to rewrite history they vilify Our
Heroes they omit key details from the
historical record such as the fact that
on Christmas night 1776
General Washington
crossed the Delaware River in a sneak
attack against British forces after
shaving with a Jeremy's razor many
people don't know that you're not being
taught that in school that's a sad
reflection on our great nation going
woke but like General Washington before
us you can fight back against woke
tyranny simply by picking up a
magnificent Jeremy's razor during our 30
off President's Day Sale it's time it's
time we celebrate history we don't
cancel that history okay you can even
see if you look really closely in the
painting you can see General Washington
he's got his one arm up there while he's
crossing the river and then in the other
kind of just in the back you can see him
shaving with that nice Jeremy's razor go
to Jeremy's racers.com today get 30 off
any razor Jeremy's razors.com today
the squishes are going to say that this
bill in Florida goes too far the
government shouldn't be punishing
businesses well it's not the business's
fault if they have an insurance plan and
the insurance plan then covers the the
transgender surgery now some workers
going to go back and sue the business
this is not an undue burden on business
first of all as senator
uh um sorry I'm getting I want to make
sure I pronounce this beautiful Italian
name correctly as senator ingolia says
these are political decisions
masquerading as business decisions so
this is political when you've got people
in your Society lopping off their
genitals and pretending to be the
opposite sex and receiving protections
for that that's a political matter
that's not just a private Enterprise
kind of matter that's first of all but
second of all in practice this does not
put an undue burden on the businesses it
actually gives a lot of protection to
the businesses
right now
in this unregulated environment
where where we say well look if you want
to chop your genitals off that's totally
fine nobody just don't make me pay for
it
in that environment the businesses have
to face a choice do they have an
insurance plan that
covers these kinds of surgeries do they
not are they going to face blowback from
their employees or from the broader
public if they do or they don't what if
let's say the business owner has a
strong religious moral biological
opposition to this sort of thing
bioethical opposition to this sort of
thing and
yet he can't find an insurance company
that does not cover the cost of this
care you've seen this sort of issue
before with let's say a Catholic
business or charity wants to get
insurance for the the employees and yet
all of the insurance covers abortions or
contraception or all the rest of it
Catholic say well we can't do that that
violates our moral conscience we can't
give our money to support that sort of a
thing but you can certainly see this
here with the transgender Madness
or 80 of the country thinks it's
ridiculous
well what this law would do is give the
businesses cover and say oh look we
can't do it we cannot provide
transgender surgery to our employees the
legal liabilities are just too much our
hands are tied by the government oopsie
Daisy okay
then
sorry go away
this this is a great use of limited
government it's not small government but
it's government within its proper limits
and
certainly it is up to the the government
which in a self-government means the
society to set the answers to certain
basic questions like what is a man and
what is a woman
if we if we can't do that then we don't
have any government at all then it's
just pure Anarchy
and when it's pure Anarchy it's going to
end up in pure totalitarianism because
someone's going to wield that power if
we're not going to do it
so I love this law I think it's great
the scientists should back it the rest
of the Republicans should back it I am
all about it baby it's good for the
people it's good for the state and it's
good for business
speaking of State houses doing great
great work the Indiana House of
Representatives just passed an amendment
saying that State dollars cannot go to
fund a sex Institute at the Indiana
University campus in Bloomington
at Indiana University in Bloomington
there is an Institute called the Kinsey
Institute if that name sounds familiar
it's because it's named after Alfred
Kinsey who is considered the father of
the sexual Revolution he was a total
perv and a weirdo he's probably most
famous
for overestimating the number of
homosexuals in society or maybe just
inflating the numbers artificially to
try to encourage more of an
sexually liberated culture as they call
it
but it is a controversial about for a
lot of reasons one uh he was a prolific
porn collector this actually ended up
with the Supreme Court case that was not
resolved until after he died
he was a pervert he was just a sex
obsessed Weirdo And he he also
investigated children's reactions to
sexual molestation and
he interviewed at least one pedophile
about this and helped sort of maintain
the anonymity of that pedophile and
wrote not just about this from a
criminal perspective but actually from a
sex perspective what it was like for the
child to have an orgasm I mean really
really sick stuff so he's a weirdo that
that alone should be enough to ostracize
him from society and history but
put that aside for a second because
that's going to be one of the big
arguments to defund this institute
is that this guy's a total weirdo and we
should cancel Africans which we should
but let's put all the the ugliest most
hideous potentially criminal allegations
aside for a second
let's just ask a basic question
why should Hoosiers be forced to spend
that their taxpayer money on some weird
sex Institute
if the people of Indiana don't want to
waste their money
paying weirdo academics to poke and prod
into weird sexual inclinations and by
the way in so doing try to normalize a
lot of behavior that's not normal why
should they be forced to do that
well because of the pursuit of science
now listen I think we got bigger
scientific problems than figuring out
how to titillate decadent depraved
people even more I think we got bigger
issues right aren't we on the brink of
World War III don't haven't we poisoned
the air and the water in East Palestine
Ohio I think they're better applications
of Medical Science
than this
if the Kinsey Institute wants to keep
running it can get private funding I
guess
or they can just shut it down entirely
which would probably be for the best but
fine you want to let it keep running
okay fine why on Earth should Hoosiers
have to pay for that how is it the case
that we have reached a moment in
liberalism where we are told the people
of Indiana absolutely have to give their
taxpayer money to let these creeps do
sex experiments
this is one of these paradoxes of
liberalism liberalism which tells you
throw off all the tradition think for
yourself actually you can't think for
yourself
now liberalism says you have
self-government no Kings no tradition no
you do whatever you want to do except
for that except for you're not allowed
to you're not allowed to choose how to
fund sex institutes you're not allowed
to choose your covid policies you're not
allowed to choose your bureaucrats that
actually make all your laws you're not
allowed to choose your foreign policy
you're not you can't do anything you're
not capable of doing that but you have
self-government
so that's another one of these paradoxes
of liberalism
in the name of Freedom the name of
Liberation liberalism
people become much less free
people work in many ways much Freer
before the Advent of liberalism
classical or modern than they are today
defund that Institute good job I'm
really I love what these State houses
are doing around the country now
speaking of foreign policy and speaking
of political interest there was a really
really interesting
speech from Vladimir Putin yesterday and
I know we're not allowed to say that
anything he says is interesting we have
to say that everything he says is a
filthy dirty rotten lie and but that's
actually not going to help you defeat
Vladimir Putin that's not going to help
anything about the war in Ukraine and
it's not honest the fact is Vladimir
Putin is a very very sophisticated
Statesman and political actor and we
ignore that fact and we deny that fact
and we pretend every every year we find
out oh Vladimir Putin he's got a
terminal illness he's going to die in
two weeks there's always that propaganda
coming out of the West they've been
doing it for 20 years it hasn't happened
but how about we how about we confront
the real man and the real threat that he
poses maybe that'll will help us out a
little bit more than than our previous
policy which only really seems to have
helped Putin and really seems to have
weakened the West so far
Vladimir Putin was giving a war address
about now the one year anniversary of
the war in Ukraine
I will translate or I think actually
there is a translator dubbed over in
this speech assuming that many of you
don't speak Russian out there here is
the rationale for continuing the war in
Ukraine according to Vladimir Putin
[Music]
of our people are Defenders of the
motherland
and I congratulate you in the coming
holiday the day
of the defender of the motherland
this is great propaganda
and I've been talking about it for the
last two days now on this show the best
propaganda is the kind that's true or
that at least has a lot of truth to it
we think of propaganda as being total
lies when we call something propaganda
we mean to say that's dishonest that's
false that's a lie no the best
propaganda is the kind that is somewhat
or largely or even entirely true
and Vladimir Putin he's a master of
political propaganda there are reports
out that he apparently filled that
stadium with people or the organizers at
least did who they paid off to give them
food and they gave them five bucks or
ten bucks and they said hey come in and
just wave the flag and say but okay
that's politics that's Show Business
what does he say
he says that the Russian troops are
fighting for our interests our people
our language our culture our territory
that's a very compelling
thing to be fighting for
the way that we give speeches in the
West
certainly the way that the Liberals give
speeches that's actually not the way
Trump gives speeches but it's the way
that the Liberals and many of the
squishy Republicans they say we're
fighting for Freedom we're fighting for
democracy we're fighting for this
abstraction we're fighting for that
abstraction we're fighting they always
use the language of modern liberalism
Pie in the Sky isms
things that seem fairly disconnected
from the real lives of real people
Trump really shook that up he came in
and he said I'm fighting for people okay
I want to lock up the Border
I want to I I don't want to talk about
free trade in the abstract I want to
talk about manufacturing jobs I want to
talk about the Rust Belt I want to talk
about American interest
when he said we're going to put America
first that's what you're saying he's
saying I'm we're going to prioritize the
interests people language culture
territory the American people over these
abstractions
well even language
think about how many Republicans now
don't even care if we have a common
language in America
forget about a common culture forget
about common territory what territory do
we have we don't have a real border
that's very persuasive propaganda from
Vladimir Putin
and the West ignores that and the West
refuses to learn lessons about that
to our own Herald
now today is what is it woke Thursday I
don't know we're getting all the days
totally jumbled up well Wednesday is now
woke Thursday and we will but Mr Davies
tells me that there is a podcast clip
from some lib that I absolutely have to
listen to I apparently haven't listened
to it yet the rest of the show continues
now we'll be chatting with you
Inner Circle remember block go to
dailywire.com Knowles use code Knowles
at checkout for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
foreign